hi everyone i am super super excited
because i have
my best friend here with me and also our
latest field trainer
husley hi guys hi husband are you
excited for today's challenge yes i am
today we're doing a 500 plank
and crunch challenge so get ready
because
we're going to get your abs on fire and
to strengthen
your meat section and if you have your
friends with you grab them and let's
finish this challenge together
so let's do this
there will be two runs for each round
there will be five
exercises and the goal is to complete 25
reps for each exercise and we want to
repeat
the round twice through okay so at the
end of this workout
you will have completed 500 reps
so let's start by getting your call
warmed up so throughout the workout we
will be on our mat all right
so let's start by getting into a plank
position
start on your knees okay i want to start
by doing some plank to downward dog if
you want to you can also start
on your palms all right so let's get
into a plank
a full plank remember that in when
you're in a full plank you want to make
sure that your back is always flat and
now pike your butt
up slowly push your butt up feel the
stretch
on your lower back and back to
a plank so remember shoulders and arms
should be in line again
push it up and back down
so today's workout is all about
controlling the movement
and engaging your core okay we're not
rushing through the workout
two more times one more
start to feel your body warmth up and
now slowly
drop back down onto your knees now let's
do
bird dog okay so i want you to raise
your opposite leg and opposite arm
and remember that your hips should be
squared
so do not tilt or drop your hips okay
square your hips engage your core again
up
and gaze gently onto the floor
left point your toes back down
back flat and
down raise your core
tighten your abs back down and just keep
a neutral spine two more
left and
up and i'll just stay here
stay in this short plank position now
tuck your toes under
what i want to do is hover your knees
off the floor
hold it for three counts drop it back
down
and hover it off the floor this is just
your warm up okay
this is due for you to start engaging
your core so off engage your core
back down again up
and down up
and back down and last one
up and slowly back
down okay so you should feel the
engagement on your core
you should feel that your body is ready
all right
now let's start with the first workout
the first workout is going to be a plank
okay
it's going to be a plank cross tab so
start in a high plank position
all i want you to do is release your
right hand
and try to reach for the opposite leg
okay keeping your legs straight
and reach all right got that so now
let's start our count right now
left and right will be two remember pike
your butt up
just like how we did in the warm up just
like a downward dog
reach back into a plank
reach and tap if you find that this is
too difficult
what you can do is to keep a slight bend
in your knees okay if not
straight legs back and
tap good that was 10 we have 15 more
reach and really feel the crunch on
your abs crunch it pick your butt all
the way up
and crunch very good
and remember breathe okay breathe out
as you crunch good job
let's go for five more
last three more breathe out
that's one more and slowly
come back down all right now
get onto your butt okay so we're
alternating between planks
and crunches the next one my favorite
knee tucks so i'm just gonna place my
feet forward
i want you to support your upper body
onto the floor
with your arms and what i want to do is
reach forward
tuck your knees in reach and tuck your
knees in
okay are we ready haas yes let's go
let's go 25 okay
reach target reach tuck
again you can always choose a regressed
version
which is to tap on the floor come back
up
tap and come back up good
now let's count together 8
9 10 good 15 more remember
your arms are just supporting your upper
body okay
so you should not be pushing using your
upper body
last eight more seven
six plus five more
and good job
are you feeling the bird ah yeah i know
i am can you feel your lower
abs working yeah yeah that's good okay
now
back into a plank the next one is going
to be plank hip dip
this is actually my favorite so i want
you to start in a low plank
get onto your elbows okay remember same
thing shoulders in line
with your elbow get up back flat okay
do not pike or do not dip back flat
and all i want to do is dip your hips to
the left
and to the right okay so remember it's
not
this back flat and deep ready let's go
left and right will be one alright
so side to side really feel the work
on your obliques
[Music]
and just keep breathing
this is a love-hate relationship
keep going
we are 10 let's go for 15 more left and
right
do not stop right now
dip aim to get your hips as close as you
can to the floor
that's five more stay strong strong core
come on last two
and one
well done okay all right
you know it back to knee
raises okay so now lie back down
on the floor so what i want to do is
raise both legs up
into a 90 degree position and all i want
to do is slowly in a controlled manner
lower your legs down tap the floor
gently
and as you raise it up lift your hips
off the floor okay
so it's a nice and controlled movement
do not collapse your legs
so gently up lift good
that slight lift will really activate
your lower abs
and remember to breathe out
as you lift your hips off the floor
tap good job small movement but do you
feel that work on your car
good let's go 15 more
tap up don't rest okay it's just
a gentle tap and up
keep going
last seven more push
push good job five more
strong core last four more
i told you your abs will be on fire last
three more
two more up
and slowly gently
lower it back down okay good job
now let's get back up okay
the final workout is going to be a core
blaster
plank jacks so we want to increase your
heart rate slightly
so get into a high plank position you
know this
let's check it out and jack it in 25
times to end this round
are you ready justly yes i am let's go
out
and in good keep your legs light
keep your body light feet light and
keep in and out that's ten
let's keep going remember back flat
keep a neutral spine last five four
three two one okay
very very good job so now we're
repeating the entire round
one more time you have completed
125 reps let's go for another 125
reps okay so start in a high plank
position
let's go for a cross tap so reach
and reach good job this time
i want you to challenge yourself really
pack your butt
all the way up and reach as far as you
can
and feel the work on your abs
crunch keep your back flat
and push in to
the ground remember to breathe out
as you crunch
we have ten more all right we're strong
team
let's go reach
good job this will really work on
your hamstrings flexibility as well
last two more
and last one and drop
back down okay get down
on to the floor knee tucks okay
it's a great workout it's really good to
get your abs on fire
all i want to do is focus on your core
relax
your upper body okay so gently place
both hands onto the floor ready let's
extend our legs out
crunch it in and crunch it in so drive
your chest
in towards your knees
six seven eight
nine ten fifteen more okay
knee in towards your chest
focus on your core
breathe out as you crunch in
that's five more
three four
five oh my gosh okay
okay now let's get back into
a low plank this is actually my favorite
husky doesn't like this workout at all
no no no
i think it's actually a female's
favorite i don't know let me know in the
comments below if you love
playing hit dip all right okay start
in a low plank position ready left and
right will be one
okay so remember maintain a flat back
do not pike your butt up
and keep a neutral spine
i know this might not be this might not
be where you want to be right now
but just focus on the end goal okay
our angle is 500
reps so you got this you're almost at
the end
of round number one keep going
left and right drop it
raise it up working on your obliques
pull it up
five more
keep going
that's two more
and left and right
okay all right get back
down okay you get to lie on the floor
but
we're still putting in the work all
right
so remember place both hands on the
floor next to you okay
if you feel that the strain is too much
on your lower back
what you can do is place both hands
underneath your lower back
just for the extra support all right and
again remember to raise your legs up
into a 90 degree position and it's just
a gentle tap
and come back up okay lift your
hips off the floor feel the crunch
on your lower abs and
back up so there should be
some support on your lower back by
placing
both hands underneath it
up back down up
let's go 15 breathe more
up
my abs are on fire
husley is strong and that's why i love
to have a workout partner because
there's someone
push me through the end
five more
last three last two up
last one more stay with me up and slowly
drop back down
okay final cardio blaster all right
ah plank jacks come on
let's do this okay 25 reps and you get a
short
break ready stay in a high plank
let's jack out and in let's go
three four five six
seven eight nine ten count with me
two three four five
six seven eight nine
ten last five more five four three
two and one whoa
oh my gosh well done high five
that was the end of round one you have
completed
250 reps take a short break
keep yourself hydrated and for the next
round
husley will be leading you in the next
round
so let's do this take a break guys
all right guys welcome back so just as
joanna said we've done
250 reps and you know it's a 500 plank
and ab
crunch challenge so you're halfway there
round two you'll be with me with another
five
more combinations of planks and crunches
okay so if you are ready can we get
started again so excited all right let's
do this let's do this
with first movement is thread the needle
side plank so
one arm directly under your shoulder now
join us going to show the regressed
version
what we want to try and do here is to
keep that palm hip
and legs aligned so you can see that my
legs are just slightly apart from each
other
okay we're gonna take the other opposite
arm straight up straight direct one
straight line
and we're gonna coming back down thread
the needle through the hole
and up all right that doesn't count
let's start counting now so 25 reps here
good so what we need you to do here is
control that balance
while your body is moving
your core is stable so that you can keep
that strong position yeah
that's the challenge right here okay
guys
you're at seven right now and if you can
your head follow your palm so look up
and look down all right 15 more to go
lift
and drop and if you just haven't noticed
we're doing it only on one side
it's going to go on to the other side
soon yeah
okay we're going to go for 10 more
10 9
8 you should start feeling that oblique
burn
and your stabilization challenge
seven six
five
three two
one okay good
body is shaking all right guys so you've
done one side
and we're gonna repeat this on the other
side at the next set so we move on to
the next
exercise which is your star crunch so
this is the same thing you're kind of
going to go down onto the mat straighten
your legs
reach your arms out to the side all
right joanna will show the regressed
version
okay and i will do the normal version
where we bring it up
take your right arm to your left leg
that doesn't count let's start now yeah
one and two
three what i need you to try and do
is keep your eyes looking up to the
ceiling so that you don't really strain
your neck with this movement yeah
okay gang we're almost at ten all right
now you have 15 more to go
so we're taking that cross movement to
work from the obliques all the way down
to your lower abs
nine eight
[Music]
and breathe out five good journal
four i have someone to help me here
three
two and one more one more that's it
okay roll yourself back up so you've
done the crunch let's move on to your
plank variation
next one is your plank and shoulder tap
so you're going to come to a full high
plank
palms directly under the shoulders come
to a full plank here
regression is to place your knees joanna
will be showing you that in a while
all right so whichever you are feeling
today just go for it and commit
so we're going to do is while you keep
this position you're going to lift one
palm
touch the opposite shoulder and that's
going to be
your plank shoulder tap all right we
have four
the whole idea here is to actually
challenge your balance
of your core and engagement while you
move
your joints yep which is now your arms
hold on in here strong one
yeah at 11. like i said again
control is key we are not going to rush
you through this movement
what we need you to do here is to commit
to the control
and focus on that core engagement
five four
three two
one huh good
so you're done with the plank and
shoulder tap we're going to go back down
now on seated position and slowly bring
yourself down i'm going to demo this
first for you
we call this the knee raise roll up so
i'm going to do a full version
joanna will show the regressed version
so remember the knee raise this time
you're just going to have a little push
use momentum to shift the body up and
lift your arms at the top
all right one more time this one and for
joanna
looking at the regress version just come
up with a slight crunch for that upper
ab
alright guys 25 let's go you ready for
this joryna
yep up so guys
like i said you're playing with the
momentum here
softly bring that lower back down to the
mat
[Music]
no sudden thud on the ground it's all
about that control
firing up the whole core region
guys you're reaching 10 okay so you have
15 more to go
how you doing joanna
yeah you should be you should start
feeling it as well guys
all right i'm gonna give you a countdown
because we're now
10 reps away ten good
nine
eight no matter how tired you are you
just need to keep that control
always in check all right
guys almost there i know
five more let's push through this
i can't lose to joanna right yeah two
and done all right guys now
another core blaster just now we did
playing jack with joey now you're going
to go across climber with me here
so full high plank palms underneath
cross climber means knee to opposite
elbow try and reach it and come back
i'm not going to rush you here i want it
controlled and i want you to control the
movement within that range
ready 25 let's go one
two three four
knee to elbow
eight nine ten
bum doesn't come up yeah bomb stays down
guys you have ten more ten nine
eight seven six
five
two one all right
guys shake it off shake it off so first
look at that yeah we're gonna start
all over again so this time again side
plank thread the needle
but on the opposite side all right we're
gonna take that palm down
come to a side plank position choose
your option
and then straight arm up all the way
align with that bottom palm
all right let's go for 25 here shred
that needle down
control that oblique control your
position
and get your core and stabilize it here
good gang
we're at five just five
i know right seems like an eternity
does it feel better if i tell you we're
at 10.
all right guys 15 more to go 15 more to
go i know stay with me
stay with me we are strong we are strong
and together even stronger guys let me
count you down
all right in 10. that oblique is just
burning
nine 8
7 6
5 4
3 two
one take it down ha
i really feel that burn just right there
guys all right coming down
let's reach for the stars with your star
crunch
okay guys legs out straight right hand
to left leg let's go one
and switch the other side that's it
that's it
it's all about that range and that cross
over yeah
guys you're coming to nine and
ten fifteen more and we can actually
start seeing the end of this whole
workout already yeah
almost there so it's not the time to
think of giving up
but time to find whatever you have in
you to continue on and finish this
challenge
alright guys i'm going to count you down
we're going to go
in five
four three
two one and that's done
all right guys come on up back to that
plank position for your plank
and shoulder tap all right stabilization
engagement while other joints are moving
let's come
up and let's start with your left hand
let's go one come down
two three
four realize how i'm not swaying
my hips and my hips not coming up to a
mountain yeah
so i'm just holding it in this plank
position
15 more reps to go guys
[Music]
guys 10 more ten
nine eight
seven six
five four three
two one okay oh my gosh
ah all right guys yep 50 more guys
so the last two more exercises down
roll up yes knee raise roll up
hands out now choose your option lift up
and go up so either you come all the way
with me
or come to a crunch with joanna
yes both effective
choose where you want to be today yeah
there are five here
[Music]
i cannot stress how important it is to
control that movement down
and to softly let that lower back
land on the mat and use that momentum to
come up
all right lower abs burning right here
when you control that lift
and coming up all right guys seems like
a long time but we're only at 10.
yeah oh jordan can you believe that
let's go
nine eight
seven six you with me join us
yes come on guys five five let's go guys
four three
two one more guys
one now let's finish it off
and climb to the top all right your
cross climber
closed climber come on come on in full
plank position
get that neutral spine in and get your
core ready
right knee let's go one two
three four five bring it all the way the
end to the elbow
seven eight nine
ten women guys i'm going to count it
down with you very very soon
all right let's go for ten more yes ten
nine eight seven
six five four
three two one
we're done we're done high five give
your friend or your partner a high five
because
you have completed 500
plank and crunch challenge very
very well done i hope you feel that your
abs are on fire right now i know mine is
mine is oh my gosh towards the last 50
reps that was the hardest but you pushed
through so well done very very well done
haas thank you so much for being here
for those of you who enjoy this workout
session
be sure to let me know in the comments
below you can also hop on the field and
check out a lot more
hit workouts and also a music based
workout
with hazley yeah he will be instructing
on
the field app and i will see you next
time be sure to continue on with this
challenge
every single day or every alternate days
for the entire month
and let me know in the comments below
tag us on ig
joanason official or husley bojili
and let us know how you get on
now it's time to take a break all the
best bye
bye guys